[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the first
annual video game accessibility awards
i'm alana pierce and this
is my very handsome co-host and eye
candy for the show
steve spock that's me thanks for letting
me come along and be adorable
wait hey somebody has to wait wait wait
wait wait what what is this what is this
a dress
and red carpet and you you did not i'm
in an office you did not
want lipstick steve wow
i am still wearing pants would you just
a shot of the illusion of how fancy this
is
all right yep are you are you allowed to
show pants
on the stream is that i think so it's
too cold and i guess my socks are green
but uh i did try to dress up for the
event so thank you to everyone for
joining us
you know when i go to kevin so so after
that hey kevin can you uh can you make
some magic happen in the background here
on it oh man look at that
oh yeah okay i like that our whole award
show actually takes place on a red
carpet because we couldn't get a venue
doesn't matter we made it work which is
very related to things we will talk
about about how difficult the show was
to put together but first
steve what are we doing tonight well
lana we
are here tonight to celebrate
accessibility and
to celebrate video games so
for the first of uh our lives we we're
living in an era where accessibility is
finally being celebrated
you can see it throughout the game
industry you can feel it in
social media spheres you can feel it in
the industry things are changing things
are getting more
accessible and we wanted to come
together for a first of its kind way of
celebrating that
now we're going to talk about this
throughout the show but this is the
first of a kind
we're going to mess things up we're
going to have points where
we we miss some queues for example like
we would love to have an esl translator
right now
you might notice our closed captioning
by the way at not
yeah i available we basically wanted to
come together and celebrate
uh games that are doing accessibility uh
right or rather are making struts a
taking step forwards to making things
more accessible and i for the record
everyone who's watching
this was a show that i had pitched 12
months ago that was supposed to be
sponsored
that was supposed to be a live event it
was supposed to be very different to how
it actually turned out and there was a
while where i was like well maybe it'll
just be too difficult and then i decided
that that would be sucky and you
shouldn't not do something just because
it got
harder so now the show is sponsored by
alana pierce
um i know steve really wanted doritos
uh but we couldn't we could make that
happen
and then they blocked me and i don't
know what's up with that super rude
uh so so we did our best but of course
you know um
where we're totally happy to hear
feedback on categories we want this show
to just continue and get bigger and
better as it goes on to become something
beautiful um and and really try to
celebrate everything is what we're here
to do
have a celebration of video games and
also hopefully teach some of you who
don't know about some of the cool
accessibility options out there
about them um like for one thing that i
did want to mention regarding categories
is we don't have a hardware category
uh but you know shout out to xbox for
the adaptive controller that seems like
an
easy one um but steve do you want to
tell us a little bit about how
the voting process worked yeah
absolutely so
when we thought about doing the first
awards we thought you know what let's
just pick everything ourselves and then
everyone will love us and they were like
no that's not how this should work in
fact we should get disabled people
involved so this entire process has been
entirely driven by the community and by
disabled people ourselves so ablegamers
has set up an amazing
program called player panels which is
an entire database of people individuals
who are ready to be q and a testers
ready whenever the industry calls if you
need someone to test out to make sure
your game is ready these player panels
are ready for you well we decided to tap
into that knowledge and extensive video
game love and say
hey what are some great examples of
these
here video games and you can see these
categories on screen we have very fancy
graphics we have a second channel
graphic on the screen right now with
some same controls are different they're
little blue
graphics with blocks and pixels full of
different
uh icons that represent exactly what
accessible
design patterns we would be talking
about and we're going to get into a
little bit later i'm not going to spoil
it too much right off the bat but we
picked some of these to go into and talk
about
how games did really well in those
particular areas
also does one of you have construction
in the background
ah that might be me i love it it's
perfect
for everyone sorry
for everyone who's asking in chat uh
very relevant this is 100
live uh and yes yeah this this all the
captioning is live and
it's very good um i hey i hope that
cooking's good kevin
i'm happy to hear it have a good time
if you're gonna build a pool in the
middle of a live show why not this one
honestly can i come use it that's all i
want to know that's all i'm asking and
then everything is fine
um so i did i did also want to mention
before we get into everything because
obviously we start with a million
disclosures
uh this was my call not steve's or
ablegamers and that is an important note
which you can elaborate on a bit steve
um
that we are going to try to raise money
for ablegamers throughout the stream
basically to spread the good vibes it's
just like if you're here and you feel
inspired or or you want to
feel like you could do something good uh
i'm trying to raise five thousand
dollars for ablegamers tonight
um but ablegamers ultimately i mean
steve again you could speak to this
didn't just
put together an award show to try to
make money that's not what happened this
is completely independent 100 my call
i will throw the link in all of your
chats right now
it's 100 percent uh all on alana blame
her for everything
uh that's alana aol.com
you did um so uh you can
well so we we love to raise 50 million
dollars tonight uh probably 5 000 a
little more tangible
uh but you know when lana and i started
talking about this
here's the thing right uh we didn't want
this turned into an advertisement for
ablegamers it's about the entire
community it's not just about us
ablegamers is one of the most well-known
names in accessibility
and yes we have a giant force behind a
team of people who are coming together
to make the world a better place
but we didn't want it to turn into a
fundraiser feel
however at the same time as reminded by
my board
we are doing this we did put in the work
to build the player panels this is what
this is all around
so if people feel a resonation with the
message available gamers with
helping players with disabilities find
their way into gaming maybe for the
first time maybe coming back to it after
an injury or a trauma
then if you have five bucks and you have
the means to do so feel free to tip a
little bit of a donation but if you
don't just watch
enjoy look at the eye candy you know
check out kevin in the background
building the pool
that's right that's all you gotta do can
we get pull cam
it's a hot tub you guys know it's a hot
tub oh
all right my man hold on stream's
canceled we're going to the hot
yeah we can't stream that that's too too
much spice it's too much spice um
but yeah i keep putting the the links in
chat i believe it's in the youtube
description but i sometimes have trouble
with that
with twitch which i guess is like a
relevant thing to oh hey hey guys we've
already raised one thousand six hundred
dollars
thank you david which for the record i
do want to acknowledge that we can't
compete with the
million dollars uh that was donated
guys this weekend steve that is uh
absolutely incredible uh huge
congratulations
thank you thank you no listen um
you didn't listen that was all on me
i've been saving my pennies since i was
three years old
i've been you i've only been drinking
one percent milk because it's cheaper
than two percent
so yeah i'm gonna get on that vlog
clip the coupons alana i've been trying
to tell you about this for years
um so we did also want to speak again i
swear
we'll get to the awards any minute now
probably uh about some of the language
choices steve did you want to
talk about some of that absolutely so so
here's the thing everyone so
the thing about a first time stream is
that the reason one of these haven't
been done before is that a lot of
organizations
and quite frankly the no shade against
the big award
ceremonies out there but they're afraid
they don't want to say the wrong thing
they don't want to use the wrong
language they don't want to offend
anybody and they don't want to drag
anybody down and neither do we
however as a disabled person myself as a
lovely caring individual as alana is
as all of our people who've supported us
today who
many are disabled we wanted to put
forward our best foot and we wanted to
say okay listen sometimes we're going to
choose the wrong word this is live
there are deep-seated words that may not
be the right choice
into our brains for example uh i like to
say disabled players
a lot of people out there prefer gamers
with disabilities all right and there's
an
entire brew haha about what is right
what is wrong we're gonna try to ignore
that tonight
and focus on the main issue of
celebrating accessibility
and forgive us if we make it a word or
two wrong we're gonna do our best
to put our good foot forward and be like
hey we're doing this for the community
exactly trying to do the right thing um
we understand
especially me that all of this is a work
in progress but that is all coming
from a very good place hopefully um
so as for the games included which is
something that i had
a little more oversight over uh we kept
to focus on things that came out in the
last 12 months but did also
allow any ongoing multiplayer titles or
games of service games
that may have come out long before 2020
because i really like my lecture
i like i liked your your opinion on that
and i agree alana made a great point
that multiplayer games continue to
evolve
and they get better and we've seen games
where accessibility is consent
right i'm glad you like my opinion i
will throw you the ten dollars i
promised
uh off of the stream are you saying that
all right
i don't understand it
[Laughter]
um but yeah so your single player
experiences that are
listed in the categories here are for
this year um but
you're online or the last 12 months
rather your online experiences just have
to have
continued support in 2020. which comes
out is a lot of them
and and let's face it 2020 the year of
social isolation which is the main thing
that ablegamers combat against but also
all of us
who do advocacy we're all just trying to
find ways to stay connected in the
multiplayer games
they did great just as well as the
single player did
absolutely i mean kind of a a huge win
for
mental health in a lot of ways i think
especially for me and it's definitely a
thing that i can mention is um
we intend to have partnership with
checkpoint going forward as well who are
an organization that focuses more
specifically on mental health
and the relationship with video games
that mental health can have so you know
lots of things continuing to happen
um but steve do you want to announce our
categories
i do and it's important to take note
that we don't have as alana was saying
any hardware we don't have any mental
health categories we don't have
some things in place that we want to
have in the future again this is because
doritos has yet to return my ass
um hopefully one of these days i know
come on
um so can't wait to get that angry dm
from
doritos pr dear sir what did you call it
though
um but uh so for tonight we're keeping
to 10 simple categories that are
just our way of saying these are great
categories
representations of accessibility and
next year we're going to do a whole
27-hour show lana's not going to sleep
it's going to be great
until then uh she's like i didn't
rehearse this at all i feel like i
barely slept this week if i'm being
honest steve what are you signing me
helpful
well
so uh we have a wonderful group of
guestos who will be coming in to explain
each category
well well better than we could possibly
even do uh but the names of the
categories we're gonna celebrate tonight
are for those of you who can't wait
same controls but different second
channel improved precision
clear text do more with less play
alongside
bypass training grounds house rules
and helping hand i don't have the robot
voice to really do that
i will make that work uh as a note
as we roll each of the categories we'll
have our our guest presenters you will
have the
nominees and then we will come back and
i will re-read them again for anyone in
the deaf community perfect
so we can make that happen should we
just roll the first one i think we jump
into it
let's do it hey guys my name is
accessiblegamer
and i'm the ceo and founder of the
accessible streamers team and
i am here to present the nominees
for advancement and using same controls
but different
this category is for the effective use
of remapping controls either on the
keyboard or at the controller level
and this could either be a game like
warframe that has
a lot of remapping or a newer title
that has recently upped their game by
including
more ability to remap the controls
this category is super important to me
because without it i wouldn't even be
able to play video games
button remapping allows me to
utilize not just
the buttons that
the developer wants to place where but
the ones that are closest and most
accessible to me so
without any further ado the nominees for
this year's
the advancement using saving controls
but different
are
you gave the vikings something to fight
for
[Applause]
i really hope you make it
let's talk
[Music]
i ain't a stranger
[Music]
i just realized that um assassin's creed
didn't have an apostrophe
um so i would like to apologize for that
but let me read through those nominees
you guys ready
and we've rehearsed this voice
the nominees are fortnite
destiny 2 call of duty modern warfare
the last of us part two and assassin's
creed valhalla
why the creepy voice why every time
it's like my alexa's gonna come to life
and stab me i feel like it's perfect for
announcing video
games i'm very happy with it um do you
want to announce our winner steve you
should do your best
creepy lady voice the winner
is assassin's creed valhalla
well you have the correct pronunciation
and i do also uh
sorry i meant um punctuation i do also
want to acknowledge that
there is no way for us to celebrate
these games without um
you know an audience so we're just gonna
and then if you at home could also
yeah he sounds like a whole group of
people
he does that was amazing that was very
i'm gonna hire kevin anything
i it's like it's like we pay him and
then we don't so this is weird
um well i am but uh
i don't know the pain in three
musketeers counsel for his rent i'm just
saying
i don't know the uh chat is being
spammed with applause so yeah huge
congrats to assassin's creed valhalla
did you want to talk a little bit more
about
what specifically this award means steve
nope all right well that's the show
peace out everyone
uh so our first category tonight
we decided to focus uh on on what it is
to
have same controls but different uh as
you can see on the screen here we have
you know the entire design problem which
is essentially
if you need to use a control for one
situation but you have a different one
that you want to pull up
you should be able to do that you know
this shouldn't be a situation
where you can only push you know one
thing for one
person what if it needs to be a
different thing it's called remapping
it's kind of one of the things that is
basic in today's 2020 world right well
not every developer has gotten on board
with that and they should and this
particular design problem is simply
promoting
that cause of remapping valhalla did
that very well everybody who knows about
valhalla
knows that assassin's creed in general
is the most complex
you need a rubik's cube to figure out
how many different controls there are
and some people wouldn't be able to play
it if it wasn't able to be remapped
so there there are a lot of steps that i
feel like i've seen ubisoft take even
this year to be more accessible like the
first screen when you start watch dogs
legions and valhalla are about
accessibility which is a step forward
that is
very cool but i did also feel like i
guess we felt like we should address if
you wanted to speak about it steve that
there was
um a controversy surrounding assassin's
creed valhalla
of course they are very well deserving
of this award and it is uh
awesome that they've been taking these
steps but we did also kind of want to
address that elephant in the room i
suppose
yeah you know here's the here's the
thing about controversies
in the video game industry and
accessibility they come up from time to
time
right so as people in the community we
can disagree on many things but there is
no
stronger show of support than to say to
someone i do not share your view on all
things we've had our differences
but this is not okay and i stand with
you advocates put their mental health on
the line every single time
we have to speak up about an easy mode
about removing harmful ableist language
from a video game or adding options that
enable people to enjoy the virtual
worlds we love
we must stop the ad hominem attacks the
bullying that occurs to the people who
are just trying to push accessibility
forward
every gamer i know is a passionate
individual who loves
video games for the good of the future
of gaming we must
be better we must not attack our own
remember that advocates are simply
people
trying to make sure that everyone can
play in a healthy and safe
environment i'm also kind of really sad
that kevin didn't put up like some sort
of like gladiator background track while
i was doing that speech
if you want i can get it there's there's
the whole dmca strikes
nope we can't do that i haven't i
literally have it cued
again and i'll do the halo music i'll
just be like
and then we'll just again applause very
lucky
please club we can't buy it thank you
thank you thank you
[Laughter]
kevin so good at that honestly just
amazing
worth every musketeer we paid um you
know no listen
uh we we we really uh wanted to mention
that you know
so some things happen with a hollow that
we're not cool about the community and
we are happy
that the accessibility is going to keep
moving forward but just be better
everyone as better as you can
just be as better as you can i strongly
agree it's something i try to live by
just be as better as i can no but it's
still again
uh so this game specifically and again
ubisoft in general have
been doing a really great job of pushing
this stuff forward so still very
celebrated
celebratory where that award is
concerned um i saw some people in the
chat saying that they didn't even know
that it was an option
so very uh very cool that you guys are
joining us
and doing learning today i think so and
that's kind of what we meant by learning
and i
i think some people are like what do you
mean teach us about video games it's not
bad it's that
some people really aren't aware that
accessibility is a thing and it's
something that i'm so grateful to
my friends who have a lot of followers
like alana
who are teaching you know that you know
in fact
accessibility is a thing right and and
you know uh this is something that for a
lot of times was kind of swept under the
rug it was not important
and whenever anybody tried to speak up
about these issues they would just get
batted back down and now you know we can
band together and we can really say that
accessibility doesn't harm video games
it makes them better let's all celebrate
games together
important words good words here strong
words
happy birthday record as men as much as
i am making jokes because one of you
wrote in the script alana random joke
um i appreciate you steve i stand by him
and i appreciate him uh but i'm also
gonna move us on
to our next category let's do it again
hi my name is kate stark and i'm a
variety streamer
i'm here to present the nominees for
creative use of second channel
this category is for alternatives
in-game that can be turned on
or off to ensure players know what is
happening
this category is important to me because
i have adhd
second channel helps make sure that
games have multiple ways to deliver
information
so that if you are distracted or miss
what is going on
you are not punished the nominees for
second channel are
[Music]
you have tamed these broken kingdoms
[Music]
because of this poison my people have
known something worse than warm
i don't know it's creepy voice plan
again
are you ready the nominees i'm gonna
drag it out to make it more
uncomfortable for you
the nominees are the last of us
part two anything steve
it's [ __ ] keep going assassin's creed
valhalla
call of duty modern warfare
ghost of tsushima rainbow six
siege looks like she's staring into my
soul and like putting on pulling the
heart out of it
i live to make you uncomfortable thank
you
friend uh
the the win the winner there there's a
winner here right
the winner is the last of us part two
[Applause]
um obviously a huge
hugely well-deserved win steve i feel
like
what who said that
[Laughter]
i feel like everyone is talking about
the steps that naughty dog took to make
the last of his part to as accessible as
possible
um and to be totally candid when we
started this out
we were a little bit worried that it
would just end up being the last of us
part two show which is obviously
into their credit um tremendously so
steve like
what do you think naughty dog did
differently to make the last of us part
two stand out so much in an award show
like this
listen the the the truth of the matter
is that naughty dog knocked it out with
more than
60 accessibility settings in the game
itself and that is more than any game
has single-handedly done for one game
of one title ever and that needed to
be paid homage to now you know there are
here's a thing like even at 60 are there
still some people who can't play
the game absolutely there are but on top
of that
a lot of people now can play and that's
what we need to focus on is more people
can play this
than ever could before 60 is a huge
number
and although not every game is going to
hit 60 i think we'll see more people
doing better than just three or four
settings
i mean i hope so and i feel like that's
part of the importance of this show is
that like if any developers are watching
this
um or hear about it somehow that that's
the thing that they can take with them
right it's like here's why these things
are important here's who they matter to
we're trying to
show you the people uh that are affected
by these things and yeah full credit to
naughty dog
they they really did uh an incredible
job um and
you know maybe brought up again who
knows spoilers
uh but wow make them stay to the end
come on
yeah you gotta really gotta make that
one you know we're trying to make money
here steve
foundation slash organization okay
right those people right okay look how
much money we've already raised look at
all that money right there
okay well you can't see my eyes but they
look really genuine right now
so tears and oh oh oh are they
oh look at me i look like i'm wearing a
mask made out of donation
i love everybody oh i want to talk a
little bit about what this category
is i absolutely do thank you for that
totally not scripted at all queue
i haven't actually written that in there
so uh wait my copy says speak smart here
all right so the second channel uh the
design problem is simply this players
are unable to unreal
or unreliably able to take information
from game and or its interfaces via a
particular modality and cannot rely
solely on it for information
the solution is players can select an
additional channel of information
via modality so they can reliably take
in that information
from the game or its interfaces and
there's there's a lot of different ways
to go about this but
here's here's a good one is in diablo 3
when you have spoken
dialogue with text captioning right it's
it's the same exact information you're
getting it in two different channels and
that's what kate was talking about there
was
you know if you have adhd maybe you get
distracted and you look away but you're
still listening
or maybe you get distracted with someone
who is you know being noisy and building
a pool
in their background kevin and you need
to be able to read
uh you know you'll be able to pull the
same information in there at the same
time and that that's really what that's
all about
again apx successful player experiences
and
it's all about being able to do things
in a different way we did forget to
mention by the way at the top of the
show if you want to read along with us
it's accessible.games it's a place where
you can go and you can check out
while we're doing the show live it is a
resource that's free for all developers
and for people who want to see what in
the heck is accessibility all about
go check it out i just threw that in the
chats as well
that is accessible.games um very
important stuff and obviously a
tremendous resource that hopefully
you know the ideal is i don't know how
likely it is steve but maybe one day
this show becomes redundant
because all games are just too
accessible listen
that's that's been mark marley the
founder of ablegamers and myself have
been saying for
literally a decade and a half now we are
the only charity in the world that wants
to be put out of business
it would be amazing if games were so
good that y'all would let me move on to
one of the other
dozen things that disability needs a
champion for but right now
for me it's accessibility and until i
can bug you to help me get that
gold-plated
airline plane uh you know uh i'm gonna
have to stay in video games
i guess we'll tolerate heavy gold-plated
i does it does it affect the
aerodynamics are we gonna
yeah well no i think i think gold is
actually all bite material
no no it's very very heavy is it because
i know there are some engine bays that
are gold plated like in in
it it doesn't uh corrode easily
oh there you go how do you know this is
your [ __ ] fate of gold
are you are you a rocket surgeon what's
going on
very nice well i could yeah again huge
shout out to naughty dog and the last of
us part two for taking all those steps
uh
60 options is is tremendous
again
we're very happy with that i love where
people keep putting clap emojis
in the chat it's very cute please clap
it's really good um all right so we move
on to our next category
let's do number three
hi my name is broly lex and i'm a
professional street fighter player
and teacher and i'm here to present the
nominees for
improved precision for this category we
focus on shooters
esports games that have the ability
to allow mouse and controller zoom
sensitivity
for those who have range of motion or
difficulty controlling
that range of motion that they have this
category is important to me
because it demonstrates and shows the
love and passion that player has
to compete i for one know the
difficulties
and barriers it comes with wanting to
join a community
that's all about competition i'm happy
to say that
players nowadays have the accessibility
options
or at least more options now than they
ever did before
to enjoy a game and share that passion
with people and friends alike we as
gamers are always asked with the
question
can we do this will we do this
how will we do this and i'm happy to say
that
esports shooters allows us to answer
that question
more simply the nominees for this year's
improved position are
[Music]
jackpot don't mind if i do back off
but guys
yeah now we're talking
[Music]
i'm gonna do it in a british accent this
time just to switch it
uh the nominees for improved precision
game are apex legends
call of duty modern warfare
marvel avengers rainbow six siege it's
the same voice
it's the same voice but now it's british
i make very intense eye contact while
reading
the nominees for these categories how do
you feel
steve not with my hands anymore
that's left
[Laughter]
creepy clown music in the background
will make this complete anyway
the secret is this whole show has just
been a way for me to get my reel out
there as an award nominee
person but more importantly we have
another widow to announce
and the winner for this category
is apex legends
nailed it i uh i love apex
you played apex steve uh not as much as
you please go on i'm going to go like a
sandwich while you gush about apex for
the next 65 minutes
what i have to say that's completely
honest i really
like apex i also just think the
diversity of the characters in that game
is super impressive it's um it's a lot
of fun it's one of one of the few like
multiplayer shooters that i return to
all of the time but it won for improved
precision what does that
mean it did uh improved in precision is
when players cannot be precise
in their actions in game or its
interface the solution to this is
players can adjust the precision of
action so that they can successfully
target
move or navigate in the games or
its interfaces and and this for me
was um one of one of the highlights of
something i was able to bring to the
table when
smart people like chris power were
building this
amazing thing uh our vp we're enabling
gamers he's the smart one uh him and
craig haynes way smarter than me
they built this entire thing this is my
one contribution i did a little bit more
but don't say it's this one
um what was sensitivity so sensitivity
is so important for me i use
a 16 000 dpi mouse and for those of you
who
have never tried your dpi above 800 good
luck at 2 000 level and 16 000
um and and some games cap it some games
don't imagine that you could possibly
want it to be that high
and for some people like me you just you
can't play if it's that low and it needs
to be an
option and there's the reverse of that
too people with cerebral palsy or
tremors
they need the sensitivity to be really
low to be down in the tens
in some cases and sometimes games don't
let you go that low and
and it's really important that the
improved precision be allowed
and it doesn't harm anything in the game
to be able to move as quickly or slowly
as you need to
i feel like that's the case for a lot of
these things is it doesn't hurt anyone
else
you know just whatever what if you just
did it that would be super cool
some people just let people shoot i mean
that's all i'm asking
oh yeah that's the thing that you know
most people don't think about and i know
that's the thing that i've spoken to a
lot of of uh even development studios
about is like when they implement their
accessibility awards i think a big part
of the problem that we have in the games
industry
is it often it's an afterthought it's a
thing they do six months before launch
rather than at the beginning
which means that it is something that
can delay things significantly because
some systems do have to be entirely
reworked there are some things that are
more difficult than they would
implement in the development process so
it's something that they really need to
be starting from the jump
make it easier for them and every other
game they make going forward
um i think a thing that i don't think
anyone
doesn't want their games to be
accessible um hopefully
it's just unfortunate i mean with this
and particularly so
i i've asked a lot of developers over
the years because again this is personal
to me you know why do you set the
sensitivity cap
at 10 and what i've heard repeatedly
from developers over and over is uh
it's just an arbitrary number we just
figure we have to choose a number so we
choose 10.
it's like well but didn't you put any
thought into it nope
okay cool next question so thanks for
that
thumbs up shout
though man they're really good you can
sometimes tweet an indie dev if you're
having a problem with the game that's
really easy it's just an arbitrary
number tweet at them
and sometimes they'll just bump it up
for you oh that's awesome
yeah do you have any examples of studios
who don't yeah so the so the makers
behind raft
um raft was a really popular game where
you fish in the ocean for
junk and build a raft and save the
ecosystem and uh
yeah it was a really good game um and we
had some people
um who weren't able to play it and we
simply tweeted them and said hey
we were not doing this because the
sensitivity's captive five can you put
it up they're like sure
15 it is the next day patched um
that was really awesome and we've had
some other ones so we had world of
warcraft
and in fact borderlands devs um who
uh for the sake of their own jobs uh
never will reveal their names because
they literally went into the code to
tell us how to do a slash command
up to sensitivity because the publisher
wouldn't do it
well i respect that it's like you've got
like rogue accessibility
yeah that's awesome i love it
there's a bunch of publishers out there
going find the emails now they're wasted
they're just so inoffensive as emails
like can you imagine getting fired for
that
my gosh yeah um so to everyone who's
just joining us welcome to the video
game accessibility awards 2020 i think
we're almost halfway maybe almost what
are we on
hello it is us we are here doing not
creepy noises
hello and welcome
uh we're also raising money for evil
gamers uh i keep just
pasting the link in the chat so it
should show up pretty frequently um
for anyone who would like to donate but
thank you to everyone who's donated so
far we've raised three thousand
five hundred and seventy four dollars
and seventy five cents
of a five thousand dollar goal uh there
you go there it is
hey everyone um really hope we could hit
that five thousand just
just you know if if you um want to
contribute really more than anything um
we've got some nice comments in here
uh mark said very cool approach to an
award show might be the first one i've
ever seen where i've learned something
so
i love that that's a nice comment oh
thanks mark
yeah lots of nice stuff going on in
there so yes shall we shall we jump to
our next categories
i want to jump i do want to say shout
out to broly legs by the way
broly legs is a competitor who plays
with
his face the controller literally on his
face and he is the
sixth best street fighter player in the
world
that's incredible yeah that's that's the
coolest thing i've ever had in my entire
life
yep you imagine playing evo the evil
tournament with just your face can you
do it because i couldn't
no okay he's a trainer as well though
right he teaches you
he literally it's not what his way does
for a living literally teaches people to
be as good as him and he's got some
amazing students and he's out there
making a difference in that community so
shout out to him one of my favorite
dudes on the planet
that is very very very cool uh obviously
we have a lot of very cool presenters
but did you want to tell people where
they could find him if they'd like to
check out
i do uh his name on twitter is broly
legs you can go check out his sweater
watch his videos and go watch his
competitions
it's a good chat everyone get on it um
all right
let's jump to our next category hi
i'm steve saylor commonly known as a
blind gamer i'm an accessibility
advocate and consultant
and don't mind laniardo back there we're
both actually dressed up in in you know
in fancy suits
because only stephen and alana can be
able to get us to dress up
in the year that is 2020 and we're also
very fancy today because
we are honored to be able to present to
you the nominees for clear text
slash crystal clear text award for this
category we focus on games that have
done an amazing job
showing text for low vision players
gamers with color blindness and
deficiencies
as well as players with learning
disabilities this category is super
important to me because there are many
times i play games
that has very little text and it's very
hard for me to be able to read
and i'm playing with a 50 inch tv that
is sitting a foot in half away from me
and there are some games that i'm just
not able to play well the nominees that
are going to be in this category have
gone
above and beyond what is expected and be
able to create an amazing experience
for clear text and crystal clear text
for those little vision players
so without any further ado the nominees
for this year's
clear text crystal clear text award are
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
see the light in the shade
[Music]
[Music]
okay what no i thought that was like a
gonna be a jingle bell
oh wait are we dmc ed now
uh that's too many steves that's all i
have to say
listen uh the council of steve's
convened that we decided that two of us
are allowed to be prominent in
accessibility uh and that's it
no more you've got to walk on it that's
why the sleeve gap has been reached
all right let me let me read these these
uh nominees out i'm gonna do this one
very australian it's going to be a whole
new flavor you could you might still be
uncomfortable
i promise i'll do this one differently
okay the nominees for cleartext game are
the outer worlds fifa 20.
moving out the last of us part two
and world of warcraft
can't wait for the letters of angry
people i can't wait again that's alana
i am australian okay i'm allowed to do
that uh
okay gotcha okay uh do you want it you
want to announce i win
nope oh okay so the winner is
the outer worlds yeah mate nice
work nice we did it foster's beer yeah
frankie yes there is plenty of applause
in chat very good stuff very good stuff
um this this category is like obviously
something that steve spoke to me about
which by the way shout out to steve in a
suit
uh when i i saw that video i was very
happy to see you next time
leonardo i'm so mad he did tweet a
picture where his
his bottom half is not suit
it's weird that he tweeted his bottom on
twitter but okay you know what you're
allowed
listen support it
you're allowed follow me
i can't believe it's the first time
we've mentioned porn that is amazing we
made it to this point in the show well
that's so positive also
twitch ambassador by the way um
yes so basically um massive congrats to
the outer world to winning our clear
text
uh crystal clear text category um steve
did you want to talk about
you know some of the the guidelines or
some of the improvements that we need
for video games correct me i love the
foster beer barbecue did i do it
i mean you're pronouncing i was checking
because i have four different
see that are all and i was like do i
have fosters of course they don't have
fosters we don't drink faster
no okay oh
thank you kevin for backing me up when
alana let me down thank you kevin
for you bud design problem
yes players cannot reliably read the
text
in the game or its interfaces the
solution
players can change the way the text is
presented to them in the game
or its interface so that it can be read
reliably and you'll find this in a lot
of today's
top-end games um fallout 4 is a good
example of that uh fallout 76
now they all have this one things like
assassin's creed often have these as
well where you can adjust
the font size the text size and some
some cases you can even adjust like the
paneling behind there so that's more
traditional closed captioning like the
one kevin did below shout out to kevin
uh i wanted to say i feel like the outer
worlds initially when it launched and of
course you know i was not part of the
the voting committee for this particular
award show um people had a lot of
trouble
in some cases even actually seeing um
the texas
mall so it's what happened here that
they they patched it and made it more
accessible
correct yeah and and one of we were
actually really surprised to see
the outer worlds uh even getting
nominated in this category because
they they did not do well at the initial
onset
but again that's something that we will
talk about continually tonight now that
we're near the halfway point is that
uh games should be applauded for when
they do better and we should be able to
hold them with polite
constructive criticism when they do
wrong yeah if if you
need to be able to see the text more
clearly you should act them and you
should let them know and in this case
enough of you sent the ads and they
heard you and they decided to
make things better for everyone i mean i
feel like that makes this
like an extra special award in my
opinion is that it is
awarded to a studio obviously made by
obsidian
who learned um and they're winning the
the award for
learning through that process as well
and making improvements in terms of
accessibility which
um you love to see i do love to see it
you know again i want to call
to bear here that uh alan and i did not
pick these winners and had nothing to do
with the winners whatsoever
uh for the voting no coercion we didn't
offer them kitkat bars although i did
try to get world of warcraft in there
didn't happen uh tried and failed
to get cats yeah um again dorito blocked
you on twitter
um we just we really you know we were
really open to being suede with candy
but nobody went for it
no no i'm sorry just just to be clear i
am getting the milky ways that i was
promised though right
no no no definitely not well well
i i got you um like the drugstore
version i should afford the
cheap version of milky way milk pathway
[Laughter]
we didn't expect this win but you know
what i am glad
that uh the players have spoken and had
their their say
and you can't argue with a bunch of
people telling you that you know this
game helped them right
yeah absolutely um i'm very glad that it
did it's a wonderful rpg that does have
a lot of text because obviously there is
a lot of speech
in the game a lot of talking um it's a
great game i really really really
enjoyed it and
it's we're getting we're getting live
and chat right now
we did it how much everyone that
thank you all so much for donating i
will keep dropping the link in there
because we can exceed it
yeah yay thanks mike that's that's
sick i don't know why i've suddenly
decided again
is it not good it's sick uh
seriously you guys thank you so much
that's incredible like a texas by the
way of australia what was going on there
i think i can do southern as well that
thank you everyone for donating i don't
know if it's texan though or it's just
kind of kind of southern that's bad
video game actress by the way which is
funny because i i said this the other
night but i still maintain
um as a side note the games where i'm
doing my actual accent i think my
performance is bad
the ones where i'm doing a foreign
accent i think my performance is good
it's very very strange when i sound like
me i'm like atrocious
but when i sound like someone else i'm
like hey that's pretty good so i don't
know if that's a mental thing or if it's
actually my ability but anyway that's
the side
thank you all so much for donating uh
i'll take taping donations
did i say teep caking keep caking we're
gonna get cake everybody
this red carpet was really expensive
alana is the upper wing for the cakes
everybody you're getting the kick you're
getting the pay congratulations chat
oh man no no seriously though uh shout
out to all the people donating uh we're
halfway through
maybe we can hit 10k that'd be awesome
here's the thing uh the million dollars
to ablegamers from twitch was amazing
but that's half the money it takes to
run able gamers for one year
it costs anywhere from 350 up to 850
for the average controller but when we
help a hospital it's more like 20 000
so you know depending on what we're out
there in the world doing uh you know
every dollar helps
you know it's that starfish example you
know you might not change the world with
one starfish but you can change the
world for a starfish
that's what my ex-boyfriend said me too
yeah that was a good joke
i feel like i didn't get enough credit
for that starfish anyone that was a
really good joke
i'm sorry if you're saying very serious
thanks again
uh i really appreciate it i'm here to be
forgiving you talk to my agent
[Laughter]
kevin how did you get me on the show uh
kevin
shall we just you know move on from that
and jump into the next category
hello my name's role coley and i am
actor um
i don't think you have seen me in
anything really um i am a gamer too
so i know that a lot of you playstation
fanboys out there
will recognize my voice as bars in gears
5.
um anyway i'm here to present the
nominees for the do more with less
category
this category focuses on games that
allow you to reduce the number of inputs
needed for the same amount of actions
and this is helpful for gamers with a
broad number of physical disabilities
the nominees for this year's do-more
with less award
[Music]
are
you have no idea what you're walking
[Music]
into
[Music]
ah here we go again all right nope
please
take the floor no it's fine i'm fine
i'll be over here
the nominees further do more with last
game category art
goes to sushima the last of us part two
is i think so
elite dangerous and rocket league
uh i want you to know on behalf of
jacksepticeye that he's not going to be
happy with that accent yeah
i am friends with both of them and i
hope they aren't watching those two
specifically everyone else can watch and
it would be wonderful
those two specifically i think they're
asleep
listen my favorite ever was i did this
accent one time for daniel dwyer and
he's a really good friend of mine but he
stops me looks me cold in the face and
goes
don't ever do that again i'm like i
think you sound great as a non-irish
person who's never been to ireland
i agree i think it's somebody who
doesn't understand how to do an irish
accent i'm doing well
hand one uh the winner for the best
irish accent i've ever heard in
in my entire life including better than
jacksepticeye and danny
steve uh but who won the deal with less
game awards steve
do more with less and the winner is
wrong
so i will say uh this category pertains
to
a particular ailment that i have
um i have tendonitis in both of my
wrists which means that i cannot do any
rapid tapping in video games
i have trouble with games like guitar
hero i have a lot of trouble with
fighting games despite really loving
them
anything that requires rapid thumb
movement um in some cases also qtes
because they can be so fast
that it can be very difficult for me to
move my thumb that quickly uh so
this is the category that can be really
really disappointing to me if i'm
playing something
and the accessibility options aren't
there the most common one for the record
is to turn multiple button to perhaps
into a hold
um so there are some games do this very
well after the record goes to sushima
does do a great job and has that
particular option
um but you know there have been games
that i played in the last year that i
really love that i can only play for an
hour at a time because it becomes so
painful
so um definitely an important uh
category for me and
can say you know i was getting nervous
leading up to the go to sushima
multiplayer raids about how that would
work but it's something that
um they accommodated for that i was so
so happy to hear about because i really
love ghost tsushima so
uh steve did you want to explain it from
your end what is the do oh right well
just keep saying answer the next kevin
roll the next one
[Laughter]
i mean we could but i did first want to
address also before you even address
that there are people in chat making fun
of rahul
um he was joking uh funny
though i've seen the video like five
times and it gets me every time
he was there like people being like lol
idiot
he is in the game and does know that
a joke okay steve go ahead
can't wait for those angry emails to fly
all right so
let's do more with less categories
players cannot successfully undertake
a sequence of actions required by the
game alana put this very gracefully
earlier when saying being able to tap
and having changed it to hold
players can then reduce the number of
actions in the sequence so they can
successfully make progress
in the game there's a lot of them out
there uh most my most favorite one
listed on the website is
nier automa which uh literally you can
play the whole freaking game
uh by like one or two button taps yeah
it has
uh they're called auto chips um
yeah that is so cool yeah yeah
and then again some people don't like
this because it's practically watching
the gameplay itself other people call
this cinema mode
listen at the end of the day if that's
how you enjoy playing your game is how
you have to play your game then i think
you should be able to do it and the uh
you know doing more with less is one of
the ways that we get there
and uh what's great about this is this
is also often
uh where the modes come into play
sometimes you want to do more sometimes
you want to do less and sometimes
it depends on the day depending on your
disability or how you're feeling
i challenge anyone out there to tell me
you've never had a day where you're
picking up the controller and you're
just like ugh i'm not feeling like
mashing these buttons today
like it happens to all of us and i think
a really important distinction about
um a lot of these categories but this
one as well is
sometimes like for something like this
where i say i can't rapidly button tap
it it is physically painful my hands can
be sore for days afterwards it's not
something that i can do
uh and if i've ever expressed i wish
that there were an option for me to hold
i will get some feedback from people
that i like but that makes the game too
easy that's missing the point of the
game
and i think the best argument to make in
response to that is it's not that it's
making the game
too easy for me it's making it possible
for me to play
technically at the same difficulty that
you would play it so it's not that um
even you know with the conversations
around uh
sakura having an easy mode for example
uh are not about asking for the game to
be easy it is about asking for
people with disabilities to play it at
the same level of difficulty as anyone
else because
part of that is disabled gamers also
want to play really hard games they just
still want to be able to play them
that's correct yeah and since she
brought up sakura though i have to go do
a 45-minute speech about using it so
hang on get your popcorn here we go
now listen bring on baby ass baby mode
uh thank you brit for that amazing
catchphrase uh no it's it's listen we
want equals mode we don't want equality
mode we don't want easy mode that's
that's the thing don't let don't let
anyone anywhere in any capacity tell you
that gamers with disabilities don't want
to play games
we do we like difficult games as a
matter of fact escape from tarkov shout
out to them hardest game i've ever
played i love that game i die so much
i'm so bad at it
uh but you know what there's
accessibility in it and it makes it
playable so thanks
kind of huge congratulations sucka punch
ghost tsukushima
one of my favorite games in the world
um and again okay rahul was joking all
right you okay
um yeah and we got some love there for
brit in the chat that's that's pretty
bombastic from what's good games who i
also
um we absolutely love so let's jump into
our uh next category shall we
hello i'm troy baker 2013's most
ubiquitous actor
you may be wondering what i'm doing here
well as an actor
i've been told that my performances are
the foremost leading reason why
even the hearing community turns off the
audio
and turns on those subtitles anyway
i'm also here to present the play
alongside category now this category is
about games that allow people to play
together to progress
including quests and skills sure but
also simpler things like
lending a friend or fellow player some
gear or in-game currency
the nominees for this year's play
alongside award
are
[Music]
ready to bring down the house sugar
[Applause]
is
[Music]
damn it every time i realize he had that
accent
i liked that the whole time uh yeah
the realization on his face was it you
know
you seem very honest very honest yeah
not scripted at all
no i don't think so uh but i do have to
read the nominees
so the nominees for this year's play
alongside game award
oh borderlands 3
call of duty mobile please make it stop
elite dangerous
still going fortnite i don't get it
and final fantasy is in the mmo she
really looked really long
i don't realize it's coming every time
you're welcome that's why i paid myself
the big bucks to do this show
whoa did you get the real milky ways
hold on a minute
can't afford this no we ran out of
budget long ago we ran out of budget the
minute we hired you steve okay
oh yeah yeah very expensive also by the
way still bouncing
still don't understand that track
bouncing anyway
the winner of this category of this year
is borderlands 3.
i'm dancing dancing okay that's
oh that's not dancing that's more like
waving and wiggling
this is how i dance he's got your eyes
that's waving no you're a wave
no audacity you're not elaine for
friends that's not
that's fair i get that a lot a huge
congrats
to borderlands 3. um
steve did you want to tell us a little
bit more about this particular category
yeah so play alongside is one of
those categories that is near and dear
to a lot of our hearts even if you may
not realize that it is so players can
not progress through challenges
presented by the game without assistance
from another player
so with play alongside the solution is
players can play alongside one another
so they can progress through the
challenges presented
in the game now this is really
particularly good and i can tell you the
reason that borderlands 3 won this this
year is because i'd love to hear that
please tell us thank you for asking a
lot you can go through this entire game
and your friends can do all the shooting
all the murdering for you and all you
got to do is be there enjoying the
story and the experience so and again
this is one of the most things like no
matter what your opinion of any of the
games we select tonight
you know be it's your ah boo fortnite or
yay fortnite it doesn't matter what
matters is whether
the people who can play these games
actually want to play them and they can
through accessibility so when you know a
game has
an ability for let's say alana who is
very good at video games
to drag me through the very bad video
game player than i
am then she can just drag me along and
we can complete the campaign together
i feel like we've done that i'm not
gonna you know
elaborate too much publicly but you
weren't that helpful in phasmophobia
wow and i feel like it was more because
you're a little scaredy cat
oh very game though okay so somebody had
to
watch the van to make sure that it
didn't get stolen because what he kept
saying kept being like a ghost i'll hang
out in the truck and we're like oh
thanks steve i'm about to die
listen uh you died like a champion and
we figured out it was a demon and
i made sure that all the pens were in
order in the tray
so i mean someone had to do it
um i guess we could just just keep going
let's keep the hype train going should
we just run into our next country
let's keep going hi my name is humphrey
you may know me as no hands nz
i am the owner and creative director of
no
hands no excuses and i'm here today to
present the nominees
for bypass when you get stuck
just bypass when everything else is
right for you as a player
but it is still just impossible
skip the impossible turn your frown
upside down
with bypass this category is
super important to me as a lover of
adventure games and story games
but that sometimes you just get stuck in
because the boss
needs too many keys and too many fingers
to defeat
or the puzzles are just too complicated
and yet you don't want to miss out on
the rest of what comes in that game
uh and so for me this is a really cool
category and i'm proud to present that
the nominees for this year's
bypass award are
[Music]
me
[Music]
me
the music didn't play that time either
is it upsetting me uh
you know i'm just preparing myself
mentally emotionally it's like when the
emf 5 goes off and you're about to get
haunted
i know what you're about to do so i feel
like what
what where uh the music that plays for
the stream that you guys can all hear we
can sometimes hear but sometimes not
here so
for reference if i seem like i'm dancing
and then i'm not dancing that's the
thing that isn't even relevant to the
stream it's just us
on the back end but okay
i'm trying to figure out i don't even
know what to do this time i'm gonna do
this one
i don't know we can hear your audio
actually this is we can we
this is a post show we can have this
conversation later it's all good
uh okay the nominees for this year's
bypass game are
my friend pedro the last of us part
two sayonara wild hearts
fuser and control
i try to make it sound very formal you
sound like if alice in wonderland grew
up from the cartoon
i like that thank you it's like that's
the if i were to read a kid's book that
would be
sort of maybe how i would do it alex got
lost in the woods
and she was never seen again
escalated so badly um
wow okay creepy uh every voice everyone
she knows uh
and the winner for this year bypass is
fuser from harmonix
[Music]
in there i don't know why um a lot of
fuse all right steve i've seen i think i
saw you playing that like today or
yesterday
uh there's no video evidence of that uh
so
the yeah uh wink camera
so the cool part about fuser uh and the
reason that we gave it to them not only
because
uh number one uh when you when
we were playing to user they had them to
come by the stream
and there was a part where it would be
inaccessible
if you weren't able to push a specific
button to get by and they had missed it
and i told them about it and they fixed
it within
48 hours and that kind of dedication to
accessibility is something that i love
the shout out
and the reason that they got bypassed in
the first place and i'm so happy
that the players chose fuser was because
it has a fail-safe mode just like
rockman did where
if you're in the campaign or you're
failing it doesn't matter
because your quote-unquote not failing
anymore you are able to pass the level
and you can bypass
all of the problems players cannot
successfully engage with a part of the
game even after all possible adjustments
have been made
the player can bypass that part of the
game so they can continue progress in
the game and that's exactly what we're
talking about here
is a situation where if you're not able
to bypass uh
spiderman did this really really well
where if you weren't able to do a puzzle
you could just go into the accessibility
menu and
skip out skip the puzzles entirely
because maybe you're not a puzzle player
maybe you have a cognitive disability
that precludes you from those kind of
mini games or maybe you just don't like
them
so there you go uh you know if you're
thinking of a game and you're ever like
man i wish i didn't have to do this part
of it you realize oh
i could skip it cool i couldn't have
done this part it's much thanks to
bypass
yeah i actually have played every single
game that was on this particular nominee
list and they all
uh like cyanide wild hearts is like that
game i think does such a nice job of
basically just if you fail something i
think it's three times
it will give you the option to skip that
section um which is it's just such a
nice thing
to be able to roll through so definitely
uh an important one for a lot of people
and also sometimes just for me
when i'm having a tough time for a lot
of people and alana
was not a people i guess question mark
yes
clearly i'm a robot lady we've
established right i forgot about that my
bad my bad
but yeah i've seen you playing a lot a
lot of fuses steve you having a fun time
with it
i'm having a super fun time with user uh
it's it's been one of my go-to
vibing games in a year such as 2020 you
needed some chill out stuff
and dmca stuff aside where you got to
make sure your all
your p's and q's are lined up with your
eyes and your a's whatever else uh
language that people would use uh i'm
really happy with having a music game
that we can mostly play um
and again shout out to even a game that
wins an award doesn't always please
everybody
for example in the blind community um as
other steve could tell you
uh this game is actually failing pretty
hard there's not a way right now to tell
where the mouse cursor is
if you lose sight of it it's pretty much
like hunting for it and the things are
timed and there's no way to adjust that
time
so if you can't find the mouse if you
suddenly lose it then you're in trouble
so they still got work to do and that's
not what we're here to do we're not here
to persecute here we're
we're to celebrate and again when our
game
shows promise we keep encouraging them
to do better
exactly that's what it's all about i
think that is an important note um
and is part of like why these categories
are the way that they are and that we
don't have a game of the year category
um which we can speak to now is because
uh
in in one hand and we will elaborate a
little bit on that later is
uh some of these games can do um or take
solid steps
in one area but not in the others so
it's kind of difficult to be like well
this game is officially accessible to
everyone it doesn't
really work that way no it doesn't work
that way at all and that's what
something took a long time for the
industry to come around to is
is what you can do is you can go uh on
twitter you can go on your blog you can
go on facebook and you can talk about
how a game is accessible to you
but in order to say it's accessible and
plant the flag in the ground and yell
from the rooftops
this is accessible like you can't you
can't do that because it may not be
accessible for everyone and
if someone stands on that and says you
know well i can play it so everybody can
you gotta gotta be wary of people like
that because that's often someone who
just wants recognition for themselves
and not for the community so maybe a
little bit self-centered do you know
me a little bit maybe
a little bit when you're gonna do the
rest of the stream with this voice
any idea how playable fuser is for the
blind so i guess the answer to
that uh to death stalkers ask that
question is
not particularly no there is room
for improvement yeah um
shout out to glitch division the
community member who is
has been giving harmonix tips on how to
make it better for
blind players and uh you know uh shout
out to sk and some of the other blind
community who are on
developers all the time for hi here's
how you can do better and hopefully
these developers like harmonix are
listening and uh they'll do better
yeah so congrats defuser for winning uh
for the bypass award which is obviously
very important in its own right
but of course all of these games have
improvement elsewhere so
shall we shall we just run on through
let's jump into our next category kevin
hi my name is craig kaufman i'm the
director of community and outreach for
the ablegamers charity
and today i'm going to be presenting the
nominees for training ground
this category is about the inclusion of
a training area that allows players to
practice skills
adjust settings and get a feel for the
gameplay for those with disabilities
the ability to practice and customize
without having to be in the actual game
allows players to create a better
experience for themselves
this is important to me because i play a
lot of cross-platform games on different
platforms using multiple input devices
being able to make sure the settings are
good to go before i search
is definitely a good thing and my
teammates for sure appreciate that
the nominees for this year's training
ground award are
you look like you need a timeout
[Music]
and the winner for this category oh
you're gonna read them again
yeah uh this idea came from that and for
the record i just never want to seem
like any of these are mocking them but i
also want to make it interesting so
this year's nominees for training ground
games
are madden 20
the last of us part two among us
do maternal and moving out
oh my gosh like those are such good
games like i just can't
wait to hear like what the winner is
going to be like i am so excited
why don't you say it then like listen
like look
becky don't you even get up in it right
now okay i swear
oh it's madden 20 or whatever i didn't
know you had a valley girl living in
no you just announced it ahead of time
no he said it's about in twenty no oh
it's it eighty maybe yeah yeah yeah it
is madden 20 and i do feel like
sorry i have to sometimes just talks a
lot of crap
most games in general do a really good
job with
uh training ground uh and yeah i'm
really glad to see dubai town nominated
here that also had
um an awesome training ground that's a
lot of fun and this is a thing that i
didn't even really think about until
craig mentioned it in that video is that
part of it is just seeing what you need
to tweak in the settings menu in the
training ground before you play
multiplayer with other people
um but i guess otherwise steve why is
training ground
important could you like tell me why
like i totally tell you why it's like
those players cannot like
gain the skills to succeed in like the
game and like the usual means of like
training are used by like the game or
whatever
so like the game provides like this area
where like you go in
and then you practice and stuff and like
ideal way is like there's over time that
they can gain the skills they need in
order to like you know succeed and do
good and stuff
like it's so amazing like so good when
like you can play games and you can get
practice playing though
[Music]
i love you a lot and i also love the
idea that someone's just tuned into this
stream now and think about
what it is oh mankind divided oh that's
neat
no i i love that the first 30 45 minutes
where uh
sponsors being like you know what next
year we can get oh no
no this is like games like rocket league
and particularly overwatch
so i have played a redonkulous amount of
overwatch with my boy craig who just did
the video there as a matter of fact we
got
uh we got our golden weapons together
for those of you who don't know an
overwatch
yeah you do ranked play and you get to
get a golden weapon if you do well
enough
and uh we played together for hours i'm
a reinhardt main so i hold up a shield
and look pretty and he
runs around heals everybody it's really
fun um
but uh you know here's the thing the
training ground is what allows you to do
it if you go to overwatch right now
you can practice with a bunch of robots
with an area with no robots and you can
get better
at the game without having to put
yourself in danger of feeling bad
because you're dragging teammates down
and that's what's really really
important
overwatch surprisingly not nominated but
i guess we'll throw it in as steve's
nomination
oh craig's nomination i think it's a
craig's nomination uh
of course the winner being madden 20 and
again yeah i feel like uh sports games
do a really good job with this
in particular um
very well sir telly ho uh shall we read
the next category please kevin
hi my name is ethan nester or crank
gameplays on the internet
and i am here to present the nominees
for the house rules
category this category is all about
honoring games which enable
the player to choose exactly how they
want to play whether it's choosing the
skill level of your opponents
playing with real humans or ai or even
making
a totally new game mode within an
existing
game house rules gives us a brand new
way to play
the nominees for this year's house rules
category are
[Music]
pushing on me
[Applause]
[Music]
i really love this category mm-hmm
that's so good really cool one that's
fun for a lot of reasons uh but let me
read
those nominees can we just get this part
no okay
well but i have i'm trying to be
accessible not me
okay
uh the nominees for house rules are what
do i want to do here
um do you have to think about how to be
creepy like does it take you a minute to
build up
i just feel like i can go back to my
siri voice i feel like it's been a while
okay
oh the nominees for house rules are so
glad i brought this up
borderlands 3 call of duty
black ops 4 elite dangerous
final fantasy and
among us thank you thank you
i did it i did my job thank you so happy
that you did that
thanks friend uh so chad is asking if i
have any other voices
i do thank you very much chad i can do
an amazing british person ask anybody
who has ever met a british person ever
good day governor cheerio i am british
and this is british accent
and among us has won this category
governor
[Applause]
you paid someone to do that didn't you
that wasn't really there's no way
huge congrats to among us i feel like
this game is like
definitely some really cool house rules
i've seen uh streamers who are playing a
hide and seek mode
um people who are obviously uh the way
that you can customize the game
itself um inside of those menus you
change
things on the fly but you can also kind
of invent your own game modes which like
i said has been
very cool to watch and obviously the
game came out a few years ago but it's
still being uh supported and
updated and recently did update some of
their accessibility settings
uh which is awesome since the game is
blown up but steve do you want to speak
to this category
i do governor players are unable to
choose opponents governor
teammates or to play with who have
similar skill levels and preferences to
themselves players can then choose the
options for matchmaking skills
preferences with other players
so that they can play on a level playing
field with
others now i do want to pop out of the
horrible british accent impossibly
oh wow
live on stream um but literally
uh this this means a lot to me um
because
like alana was saying about among us
like you all saw
like the the if you're playing hide and
seek and among us it is not how that
game is meant to be played but people
found that it was fun to play it that
way and
and i'm so glad that it was able to be
that way for them to have fun now
imagine if
that's just the house rules or what you
needed to make it playable for you maybe
you can't play the slow
game but you can't play the one where
you run around and slash people with the
lights off maybe that's
you know the way you can and that's a
silly example you know ablegamers have
some really good ones on
accessible.games
where you can go see games again like
overwatch or battlefield
1 where you can choose the preference of
people that you play with
now this is a little kind of
controversial one we will call that out
there
skill based matchmaking if you talk to
any big streamer you will get a 47
minute lecture with no popcorn that's my
bonus intention
uh about this subject and they hate
skill-based matchmaking uh i personally
am more of a fan
i don't want to be destroyed by a
high-end gamer i want to go have fun
with people my level
that's my personal take on it and from
accessibility standpoint it's really
great when you can limit yourself so
that you can play
with people near your skill level so
controversy aside
house rules does rule them all it was
like a lord of the rings reference i
tried for it no if i got it
one house rule to rule them all no i
picked this one yesterday
i feel like the ideal would have have
options to have which
like i know a lot of games do uh have
one option to be
in skill-based matchmaking and the other
to not um is that not common
uh so no not all the time uh you know
and
and here's the thing is these these
accessibility things are becoming more
common
um but we've still got a little ways to
go yeah there's always a ways to go
with uh everything including the show
which
we only actually have one category left
oh my gosh
only one more creepy voice lady i mean i
can't wait i'm gonna think about it the
whole time about how to make you the
most uncomfortable
so no let's uh let's jump right to it
hi my name is radiz i'm a streamer on
twitch and i'm here
to present the nominees for the helping
hand award
this category is to honour video games
that have
options built in to allow the game to
assist you in making progress
this is particularly valuable for people
with
cognitive disabilities people with
physical disabilities
and you know honestly able-bodied gamers
can
use these options too so that everybody
can enjoy games
in a way that's comfortable for them
this category is important to me
because as somebody with a disabilities
myself
both cognitive and physical these
options being built into games means
that i can get through them
with less frustration and less pain and
it's so important for everybody to be
able to game
and enjoy video games without having to
worry about
any disabilities standing in their way
the nominees for this year's helping
hand award are
[Music]
well aren't we having a wonderful time
kicking the hornet's best
system right
[Music]
are you ready i only get to do it one
more time
okay and the chat requested it
i'm about to offend a whole country
the nominees for the helping hand game
award
in russia are the last of us
part two kevin did you just make that on
steve do that no steve did it that's
incredible
it's very good
i didn't expect
[Laughter]
the last of us part two final fantasy
vii
remake do i sound russian fortnite
how are the captions doing with my
russian oh actually quite well uh
ghost of tsushima moving out
i think i maybe sound more like borat
[Laughter]
maybe it's a difficult accent ladies and
gentlemen i did my best um
but would you like minister of russia
yes yes
i am from russia india we have a lot of
good games that have been helping him
more importantly i'm going more more
reps the more i speak
well done well done the winner of the
category is of course
the last of us in part two
[Music]
he's very good in terms of the helping
head accessibility options and then i
also
got more nasally i don't know
uh so steve do you want to break down
what specifically this category
our final category is category of
finality
for the evening helping hand players
cannot progress through the challenges
presented by the game without
assistance from the game itself the
design solution is players can choose to
have the game assist them
so that they can progress through the
challenges presented
by the game what does that mean well
take for example uncharted 4. i know
that's a fan favorite with a lot of you
out there
you can go into the game and you'll
notice that it asks you if you want to
hint
well you can take the hint if you want
if you don't you don't have to take it
that's what options are all about
accessibility settings are all about
taking the hand when you need it and not
when you don't
and that's what this category is about
as well
hell yeah love to see it yeah yeah
really well here yeah and obviously
again in a lot of cases the last of us
did really well obviously naughty dog
uh a strong point with this one and this
is something that's helpful to a lot of
people
um this also generally i know to
children
it's a good way to get kids into games
that otherwise would have difficulty
barriers that are a little bit too high
for them um even something like
uncharted can be a little bit tougher
for kids to play so it's across the
board there are a lot of different
reasons why
these categories can help a lot of
different people um and
we're very appreciative of uh all of our
nominated games tonight all about
winners um
a lot of why is that why was that
controversial steve
why did you contest that what
what you just can't help the sass it's
an ongoing
someone's gotta wait one day you know
what my mods on twitch are pretty good
at it but then
they just encouraged me to do it more
too yes well sometimes he's a very sexy
men
but this is true
all right kevin nobody asked you okay
thank you kevin but uh just to recap all
of our winners tonight which again
um a lot of really incredible games
across the board we have the same
controls but different for assassin's
creed valhalla
second channel game is the last of us
part two improved precision game is apex
legends our clear text game
is the outer world i'll do more with
last game as ghost of tsushima i'll play
alongside game is borderlands 3 our
bypass game is fuser
our training ground game is madden 20.
our house rule game is
among us and our helping hand game is
the last of us
part two
thank you to all of the people who made
the video game
and obviously that's for this early seat
but did you wanna
you wanna talk about it again did you
wanna touch on you know why
yeah i think probably for explanation's
sake especially if you missed the
monologue earlier so it was i saw a lot
of people in chat asking for a game of
the year and we're not going to name a
game of the year tonight and there's a
very simple reason for that is
it's it's almost impossible to do so uh
for those of you who know the history
available gamers uh we used to name a
game of the year and we did it for many
years uh but the problem was that
it really wasn't game of the year it was
this is the best the game industry had
to offer the accessibility community of
the year and that's a really long title
to try to like pay to put on an award
so we we ended up just kind of bashing
the program
uh because if a game is accessible to
alana does not mean that it's accessible
to me and successful to me
does not mean it's accessible to kevin
and so on and so
it's almost impossible to come up with a
game of the year that's accessible for
everyone
for as great as the last of those two is
there are still gamers that have been
left out
because they need more intensive
intervention or have more profound
disabilities that need more assistance
and maybe that's where hardware steps in
maybe that's where additional pt ot
other things can step in
you know and we we can't help everything
we can only help what we can help
that's why we're not doing a game of the
year category because none of these were
in tests
intended to be the best of the year
these are all
simply acknowledgments that these games
did well in these particular categories
and if you're a developer check them out
check out accessible.games
and if you're a player who just wants to
learn about accessibility and how
you know what why do i keep hearing
about accessibility what's up with that
alana then alana can just be like go
watch this video
here's what it's all about and of course
just to reiterate you know we
uh did not pick the nominees or the
winners ourselves that was done by a
board of people who are in
uh a lot of these cases relevant to
these categories so
that was not steve and i um that was a
very wonderful group of people who
helped us out frankly a lot of people
helping us out thank you to kevin
who is out live live for you no problem
no problem anytime
oh you're so humble about it yeah so why
because you're paying them in milky ways
well i'm sorry
milky ways yeah it's just differently
we'll
figure that out later i have to thank
uh eric sapp who made our beautiful art
here
also a new game developer just uh
recently announced a game
um kalila alston who did all of our
video editing
[Music]
absolutely fantastic um steve did you
have anyone that you wanted i do i
definitely want to shout out to
all the players with disabilities that
helped us here tonight
uh appreciate uh no hands and
kate and broly and everyone who has even
participated in the player
panels program over 600 of you and again
if you're a disabled gamer watching this
and you want to join the program go to
player panels on accessible
dot games you can check that out you can
register you can voice
it's free to join go check it out right
now special shout out of thanks to
my my boy craig at ablegamers for
helping us get this on our twitch
tonight and to
my mods along jane silver and ghosty
gaming for helping out with some of the
production
that uh kevin was like you don't pay me
enough for this and we're like fine
we'll bring it
and uh uh i want to thank also all of
the players
um this is where lana is going to be
like wow steve way to play wait way to
play into the crowd
but also listen uh it's thanks to you
that accessibility's been coming
as far as um we've been doing this for
15 years at ablegamers we're getting
ready to hit the big 16
and um the only reason the company
started listening
is because you care if you didn't care
they wouldn't care
i'm being honest with you they care
about the bottom dollar they don't care
about me some of the devs care
a lot of the devs care but the
publishing houses yeah not so much
the people bite with the company so
really what it's all about is connecting
with those people that care
so thank you for caring thank you for
pushing them um
alana i did see a message inside a lot
of people were saying like is there a
way that we can tweet a forum to be like
hey you want an accessibility award
that's not something we really
talked about i don't know if you want to
touch on that what did you mean to let
the people who won awards know that they
won
oh i am having certificates made um eric
sapp is currently working on those that
i will email to them hopefully in the
next day or two so they they will get
cute little uh certificates
uh given to them i did give some of the
publishers heads up as well we were like
considering having
uh thank you videos also included but it
seemed like it was a little bit too
difficult to put together because that's
also a reality of
making a show at home there are lots of
things that you know we
we want to improve upon and make bigger
and better and hopefully do this in
person next year if things are back to
normal
hopefully but um for the most part just
enormous thanks to everyone for for
tuning in for watching um
this is something that i personally
think is very important that
hopefully we can bring more awareness to
and more awareness equals more results
so thank you for joining me steve thank
you for joining me kevin thank you for
joining me everyone in the chat
um i hope we had a good time again
a lot more jokes than your average
awards show but i wouldn't have it any
other way
i have no idea what you're talking about
that's right
he's getting sassy again but this time
it's in seven
she's kind of helped himself it's just
you see what you see what i have to deal
with
yeah absolutely ridiculous
um so yes thank you everyone we raised
uh 5735
which is absolutely awesome thank you oh
it just went up it just went up
yeah thank you all so much um obviously
a huge thanks to ethan for the thousand
dollar donation that's absolutely
amazing and uh
we have one more video to leave you with
on our way out
but thank you all so much for joining us
for the very first video game
accessibility awards here's the next
series
all i heard in my entire life were
doctors telling me that my disability
was going to kill me
any day now but here we are september 15
2020 and i'm 40 years old
and when you turn 40 you're supposed to
do something really really big to
celebrate
problem is when everyone from medical
professionals the loved ones
constantly reminds you that your
terminal illnesses are out to get you
you don't really plan this far ahead you
don't think that the day will ever
really arrive
so what the heck am i supposed to do
last year i asked the rock to be my
friend
that worked out but how do i top that
i could have had a midlife crisis and
bought a nissan skyline but
that would require money and the ability
to get into a car
either of which i have so my thought is
this
for my 40th birthday wish i want to
ensure
ablegamers can outlive me
i'm going to swing for the fences and
try to raise
one million dollars for charity
i have poured 15 years of my blood
sweat and tears into creating an
organization
for disabled people to combat social
isolation
something that all of us can identify
with after the year 2020.
if i have any chance of making this
dream come true i'm gonna need
your help go to ablegamers.org
steve and make a donation to celebrate
my 40th birthday
every dollar helps and gets us a little
bit closer
to the 1 million dollar goal
share retweet use your social media
platform to bring awareness to this goal
raising a million dollars is quite
ambitious
and i know it's not going to be easy
but the truth is that you never know how
much longer you've got and
at the end of the day i want to know
that
ablegamers will continue on long after
i'm no longer
on this big blue marble
man why didn't i just ask for a fancy
toaster or something
maybe some gift cards the red lobster
[Music]
you